>>> WE HAVE SOME STUNNINGLY
HEARTBREAKING NEWS TO SHARE WITH
YOU THIS MORNING.
THAT OUR COLLEAGUE, OUR FRIEND
AND TRULY DISTINGUISHED CNN
JOURNALIST DREW GRIFFIN PASSED
AWAY IN THE LAST 24 HOURS.
DREW HAD BEEN WITH CNN FOR
NEARLY TWO DECADES.
IN THAT TIME HE WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR SOME OF THE MOST IMPACTFUL
JOURNALISM OF THE COMPANY AND IN
POLITICS AND SPORTS AN A GOOD
MAN AND HUGE PART OF THIS
NETWORK.
>> HE ASKED THE TOUGH QUESTIONS
AS ANYONE WHO WATCHED CNN KNOWS.
HE CHASED DOWN FOLKS WHO DIDN'T
WANT TO HEAR THEM OR ANSWER
THEM.
HE MADE A REAL DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF COUNTLESS PEOPLE.
HERE IS ANDERSON COOPER NOW WITH
A LOOK BACK AT DREW'S REMARKABLE
LIFE.
>> IT WAS SO HOT.
>> DURING HER NEARLY TWO DECADES
AT CNN, HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS
TENACIOUS REPORTING.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED YOU'LL BE
INDICTED?
>> HIS INTERVIEWS WERE
UNWAVERING.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU UNDERSTAND
HOW VOTES ARE CAST COLLECTED IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> AND HE GAVE A VOICE THOUGH
THOSE WHO DIDN'T HAVE ONE.
>> WE DON'T EXPECT IT TO BE
EASY.
WE DON'T EXPECT THE TRUTH TO BE
>> DREW WAS DEDICATED TO SEEKING
THE TRUTH AND HOLDING THE
POWERFUL ACCOUNTABLE.
>> WHAT DID YOU CONTINUE TO PUSH
THE LIE THAT 2020 ELECTION WAS
STOLEN?
>> IT IS NOT A LIE.
>> YOU HAVE NO PROOFS.
WE'VE LOOKED AT ALL OF THE
FACTS.
>> HIS STORIES HAD A REAL WORLD
IMPACT.
>> THEY DON'T RELEASE THE NUMBER
OF DRIVERS WHO ARE ACCUSED OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT TO CNN DECIDED TO
COUNT UP OURSELVES.
>> AFTER THEY QUESTIONS UBERS
ABOUT A STRING OF SEXUAL
ASSAULTS BY DRIVERS, THE COMPANY
MADE SAFETY CHANGES TO THE APP
AND REVISED ITS POLICIES.
>> EXCELLENT REPORTING, THANKS
TO YOU AND YOUR TEAM.
>> DREW EXPOSED SERIOUS ISSUES
AT V.A. HOSPITALS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, REVEALING A BROKEN
SYSTEM, VETERANS DYING WHILE
WAITING FOR CARE.
>> THIS VETERAN WAS SAYING
PLEASE DO WHATEVER YOU CAN.
DON'T LET THE V.A. DO THIS TO
ANOTHER VETERAN.
WE DO NOT DESERVE THIS TIME OF
TREATMENT.
>> THAT LED TO THE RESIGNATION
OF THE V.A. SECRETARY AND AN
OVERHAUL OF THE V.A. SCHEDULING
SYSTEM.
HE COVERED BUSINESS AND
TERRORISM, THE ENVIRONMENT AND
POLITICS.
>> MR. BURCH --
>> AND THERE WERE MANY PEOPLE
OVER THE YEARS WHO DIDN'T WANT
TO ANSWER HIS QUESTIONS.
>> PLEASE TALK TO US, DIRECTOR?
DIRECTOR?
>> DID THE BACKGROUND CHECKS OF
THOSE COMPANIES NOT REVEAL THE
FACT THAT YOU'RE ACCUSED
TOWARDURE AND MURDER.
>> DO YOU KNOW ALEX BURDMAN, A
CONVICTED FELON WHO RUNS ONE OF
CLINICS AND BILLING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR SEVERAL YEARS
DESPITE THE FACT THERE HAS BEEN
COMPLAINTS.
>> DREW ONE MOVE OF JOURNALISTS
BIG AWARDS BUT THAT NO WHAT
MOTIVATED HIM.
HE CARED ABOUT PEOPLE AND HOW
THEY WERE IMPACTED.
WILD HE WAS COVERING THE
AFTERMATH OF HURRICANE HARVEY,
HE RESCUED A MAN FROM
FLOODWATERS.
>> DON'T FALL BACKWARDS.
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
HOLD ON.
>> HIS JOB AS A CONSTITUENT TOOK
HIM ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO THAT
THESE WILD PAWNEE GRASSLANDS
WERE JUST THAT.
WILD.
NOW, ALMOST EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK,
IT IS A GAS RIG.
>> AND TO DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
WORLD.
BUT HIS FAVORITE PLACE WAS HOME.
HE WAS DEEPLY DEVOTED TO HIS
FAMILY AND HIS WIFE MARGARET AND
HIS THREE CHILDREN,ELLA AND
LOUIE AND MILES AND TWO
GRANDCHILDREN.
DREW GRIFFIN WILL BE MISSED BY
ALL OF US.
>> OF COURSE THIS IS A LOSS OF A
FRIEND PRIMARILY.
BUT ALSO A GREAT JOURNALIST AND
IF YOU TALK ABOUT IMPACTFUL
JOURNALISM, HIS STORY ON V.A.
HOSPITALS, LIKELY SAVED LIVES IN
THE WAKE OF THAT SAVED VETERANS
LIVES.
>> SUCH IMPORTANT REPORTING AND
SUCH A COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND TO
SO MANY OF US.
AND A GIFTED STORYTELLER AND SO
DEVOTED TO HIS FAMILY, OUR HEART
GOES OUT TO ALL OF THEM.
CNN CONTINUES AFTER THIS QUICK
BREAK.